so these are scary times but
unfortunately there's more to worry
about than just a global pandemic new
warning from the FBI about coronavirus
scams scams related to the corona virus
stealing sensitive personal information
it could infect your computer anytime
there's a global event the hackers like
to weaponize it so whether it's the
Olympics or an election or a global
pandemic hackers are trying to leverage
whatever the situation is against you
sir I have an old email address with a
pretty good spam filter and it's just
inundated with spam mail claiming to be
everything from the World Health
Organization to kovat 19 vaccines now
I'm not gonna take the bait
but believe it or not a lot of people
will it is working that is why hackers
and criminal attackers continue to use
it now I don't need to tell you well
maybe I should don't click a link don't
open attachments just delete it but for
many that's easier said than done
computer hacker stock footage phishing
emails have quadrupled since the corona
virus outbreak it's gotten so bad that
both the US and the UK have issued joint
warnings about the schemes so why have
all these phishing schemes pivoted to
coronavirus practically overnight so
successful phishing campaign it has to
be interesting and it has to sort of
look reliable on one hand they want this
email to look like something you're
going to get anyway but they also want
it to grab people's attention to say oh
I need to click on this urgently and the
coronavirus stuff really fits both of
those things people are getting an
incredible amount of email about it but
it's also a place where people have a
lot of hunger or for new information but
there's one ingredient the Cova 19
pandemic offers hackers that say a
Nigerian prince never could feed it is
scary millions are scared right now
I'm just afraid of this week the idea
behind these games is that in time the
crisis or uncertainty or fear people
just let their guards down
so in
cases where you know something is
promised maybe people are distracted and
not as focused on who might be sending
something or in cases where a hacker is
promising information when we're scared
we might be more likely to click on it
without thinking twice about that could
be coming from on top of the fear-based
kovat 19 schemes hackers have seized on
one of their tried-and-true lures money
the prospect of a payout from the 2
trillion dollar stimulus package in the
u.s. comes with a subject line saying
kovat 19 payment again delete it so it's
important to understand who these
hackers are and despite all the stock
footage ever made about hackers they're
not necessarily some shady dude in a
hoodie these are folks that aren't out
to sort of make a quick buck some of
these groups can make hundreds of
millions of dollars in a year and sort
of have the investments to sort of use
that money to reinvest in sort of grow
big capabilities cyber security data
suggests that many of these hacking
operations are backed by major
nation-states
so we've seen multiple state-sponsored
cyber espionage actors use coronavirus
as a lure we've seen North Korea China
and Russia all employee to try to
compromise their victims and it doesn't
stop at span mail fake social media
accounts are spreading disinformation
about the corona virus to back the
interests of countries like China and
Russia according to the US State
Department Russia has put forth its
entire just information apparatus to
spread disinformation about the crown of
virus pandemic so this includes websites
conventional media and also they say
swarms of bots on social media platforms
that are doing the work of amplifying or
spreading messages they're false related
to the pandemic Russia's motivation is
to sow discord and distrust and they're
leveraging the pandemic to create a lot
of fear and uncertainty and make people
doubt healthcare institutions just
because the 2016 election came to an end
doesn't mean that disinformation
campaigns from nation-state actors and
criminal actors didn't come to an end so
we are seeing botnets from Russia from
Iran from China perfectly willing and
capable of creating chaos through
misinformation and unfortunately it kind
of gets worse
because hospitals and medical
institutions are a favourite target for
hackers what they will do is hit a
target with ransomware which is an
attack that uses malware to encrypt or
lock down data belonging to an
organization and they'll charge a ransom
for the decryption of that data and from
a criminal perspective those attacks
might be more successful during a time
when health care institutions are so
important there is increase targeting on
medical facilities hospitals testing
centers primary care physicians because
they are so dire so desperate to keep
their operations up if they shut down
there are lives at stake just as we must
band together to defeat the koban 19
pandemic we must also be vigilant
against the people and nations
shamelessly trying to capitalize on
these trying times in terms of
disinformation campaigns it's important
to think about who you're receiving
information from trusting official
sources and not believing everything
that's on social media about the
pandemic instead going to trusted news
outlets always be on the lookout to
communication that you don't normally
get sort of the ways to check that you
can sort of double check who the sender
is from on making sure there's actually
sort of who you're expecting just
opening and looking at an email in your
gmail browser is gonna be very unlikely
to infect you but you risk increases a
lot when you open an attachment or click
on a link so you can generally read the
email and be okay but be very wary of
attachments or links especially if
they're unexpected so while we all
understand the temptation to click out
of fear or even greed please do yourself
a favor and just delete it
you
you